I gotta show you something oh wow
fantastic Wow what does this mean to you
to be part of young Hollywood how do you
how do you take that responsibility I
take it as a true honor
you know actually like in a real way my
my heart is soul just my first time
actually really know like in person I
like it a lot I know that you have a
clothing line I do I just dropped a
collection today and right now the
inspiration I use is from Martin Luther
King he wrote a letter when he was in
Birmingham in a jail cell and he said a
lot of powerful powerful powerful things
it applies so much to what's happening
right now in the world I want to give it
to the kids when the kids have had her
you know ret that non-violent direct
action program of doing exactly what you
need to do and change in the world and
affecting the world in any way that you
see that you need to and that's what
missus all about just empowering the
youth that's what I admire so much about
you that you always do use your platform
for good and to talk about important
issues what do you think we should talk
about more I think everything I think we
should talk about our feelings more on
how we feel I feel like we should just
talk about the truth more talk about
really fast your Netflix show everyone
is loving it I'm so happy to be a part
of it Netflix I'm so happy to be a part
of show that it's involving hip hop I'm
so happy to be a part of a show that
Grandmaster Flash is involved with that
nas the Baz Luhrmann like all my dreams
are coming true at the same time I'm so
happy to add on the soundtrack on like
two or three different songs like I just
feel so blessed like this is a dream
come true and like every single way so
I'm just so happy